41 anos com o senar metragem com 23 eo
passado do que o feminino são sol
despistou na a9 troca para que vocês
possam fazer um filme sobre o que o pode
ser também uma perspectiva e uma visão
para que possam ter de aumentar nossa
vida olha isto pelo início funcionário
tecnologia contra a arbitragem no
brasileiro contra nós
isso começa um clínico seis meses
a minha mãe que sempre causa do meu pai
violência doméstica um pai tinha uma
casa atrás da porta da casa dela e de
casa o véu e queria matar a minha imagem
mais fácil causa do meu pai e vai viver
com a avó uma barraca não era medalha
era tio ou então a minha vida começou
com esta partícula estado
não faltou o humor não contou que o
conceito de família e portanto não tem
falta daquilo que é o conceito pai
consegue jogar futebol muito cedo
achava que ia ser o próximo tendo
ronaldo da baliza
andrés
eu achava que eu posso ser o ronaldo
evoluiu e o articulado jogava mal era
titular dos juniores e um dia você está
falando do jogo fosse amanhã sábado de
pesca sejam as três já estava estava com
o flamengo vai à casa de banho
eu acho que há uma diferença estava
curtindo e talvez chave juvenil de
coisas e nem sintomas e nas costas e
outro réu era um treino só quero chão eu
nem o da manhã e eu então no dia e
beneficia às três da tarde a equipe e os
gatos acabam indo pra
a porta para passar de 50
eu achei que aquela pessoa a pessoa no
mundo e em uma crítica à frente aos
colegas
antes qualquer latitude onde os amigos é
um mistério ao lado
eu aprendi efetivamente nós poderemos
alcançar ao longo da minha vida
desenvolveremos ter compromisso caio tem
um carinho e um período negro da minha
vida porque não é um erro dizer que a
escola com os assentados não têm
assegurados financeiras continuar o
curso técnico-profissional imagem 69 nós
tem a ver com o som e como sabia que
seria mesmo difícil música comecei a
trabalhar como menino da mamã a vida da
noite os 21 a 23 pontos e passou pelo
sol em todas mal infelizmente nunca me
envolvi com a noite estava mas até a
manhã de hoje 23 a dispensar o
reconhecimento no brasil ganhava se
encontra na altura em que ficou 12 horas
21 horas em casa ficava com cinco
gosto porque o que estava fazendo e dá
um jornal de gustavo
ontem um dia as pessoas felizes por
qualquer coisa um ovo não lembrar de mim
a cantar enquanto idosa então federal
curso ea partir daí começar a planejar
isso funciona a enfrentar os mesmos
enfrentar os movimentos foi uma pessoa
estava emocionalmente por isso aquilo
foi um dos doze nossa senhora que eu
possa fazer a melhor defesa do mundo e
dar o melhor e portanto saber o que ela
está num campo sozinho onça chamarem
nomes o jogador respeitarem ter que
respeitar horários treinaram a parceira
nos jogos a terminar fora preencher
relatórios é o mesmo que entrou na
arbitragem dentro né
você já pensou em ser ao longe então
árbitro e fiscal lemel espetacular
tava tudo lhe posso dizer foi importante
não é eu como cenário já conquistou ver
aqui aprendi a ser líder chefe de equipa
ao mesmo tempo ele é o passado um ano e
já estava a gerir 40 pessoas ou seja
aprender na arbitragem
o irã acumule curros a conseguir dois
títulos muitas vezes parece não ter nada
a ver mas quem tem muito dinheiro então
era chamada não estou a exagerar pois aí
uma pessoa e natal uma pessoa totalmente
atinge quase sem tempo eo pensar nem
pensar que as coisas não fazem sentido
negativo estava envolvido no compromisso
e nesse sentido é construir isso me a
primeira visão enquanto a visão pela
primeira vez achei que era entrar 81
o seu pai sobre o do negro na minha vida
tive visão tinha uma visão você
internacional sobre o que acontece é que
nós quando chegar posição com 40 câmeras
começamos a perceber que às vezes nossas
decisões assertivas e chianti que
estamos em contato e bom som nós no
mundo na final
afinal não sou assim tomou pois tinha
duas hipóteses terão como fiscalizava
lógico e dizia foi prejudicados
toda a gente está contra mim em causa
está uma grande vergonha
observadores em estudo ou então pensava
no outro era os outros foram trabalhar
voltar aí foi isso que eu fiz pronto
como eles vão ter outra vez ontem estava
na segunda divisão não te aguenta jogos
em campo ao o primeiro jogo faça
internacional e no distrital encarnação
levar nossa parte dos meus avós tinham
foi teve quando eu e conseguir chegaram
a ser árbitro profissional
neste momento só faço arbitrar a três
anos a optar em curso ea carreira da
arbitragem ao onze depois fazer aquilo
que realmente acho que aquilo que usar o
gosto o posto será o tamanho para poder
compensar um trio ausência e demitiu é a
minha esposa e minha filha de oito anos
neste percurso todo ano sofreram com
esse processo porque nós pode trabalhar
nos dedicamos a arbitragem que ele
chegar longe
nós ficamos com 26 horas
tirando isso temos 24 horas no dia então
a qualquer coisa que fica pra trás e
ficou para trás a filha afirmar que não
estava lá
infelizmente estava lá quando ela nos dá
mais vou esquecer mas perdi muita coisa
do que o que é o acompanhamento eo
crescimento da minha filha o importante
é que eu nunca vou pensar em si mas a
forma que eu tentei arranjar foi
envolver forma pudesse garantir que
nestes últimos anos eu iria estar mais
próxima ao tanque e se permite ser
profissional arbitragem permitiu que
esteja envolvido mas também com minha
família que possa também ter o meu como
eu costumo dizer o meu ponto de abrigo
em que eu chego e de lei da arbitragem
de ser o árbitro e passa a ser o joão
capela pai e joão capela divino
ian serena que puxar o sequestro mas
ativo mas coloque a em um cartão que é o
capital é que tende a piorar gostoso já
conheci muita gente muitos sentidos a
partir de muita cultura em frente à
nossa disse que nós éramos enquanto
porque isso também pela europa fora e
espetacular e eu só isto porque aprendi
também que nós vivemos sozinhos não só
dependemos uns dos outros e nós alcançar
em determinadas fases da nossa vida
temos de trabalhar em equipa a alcançar
sucesso temos que construir no prazo
equipa e portanto o eu não posso
esquecer do que o sucesso alcançado
enquanto a mãe se deve muito ao longo
desta equipa
uma das mensagens que nós devemos
trabalhar em equipa e vamos definir o
objeto ser objectos com o objetivo de
cumprir objetivos reais que nós
conseguiremos controlar não vale a pena
definir objetivos sejam controlados por
outras pessoas
vamos dar o exemplo na arbitragem
existem observadores
eu não posso controlar a opinião
consumidor saem do meu desempenho
eu posso controlar é minha condição
física para fazer as 15 voltas estudar
para ter tempo de teste clínico
isso eu posso controlar o que a opinião
dos outros e já no controle não pode ser
o meu objetivo não é nossa
é mais um triângulo e esta parte do
confiança
tudo o resto é o nosso contínuo não é
inconsciente esta inconsciência
isso ocorrendo também no trabalho eo
nosso coxim é que envolve o estudo e com
os passos tomados nossas ações contínuas
e na arbitragem eu comecei a trabalhar
com psicólogo desde 2004 para tentar
controlar um sinal - fazer treino no
total em termos de que o que utilizar o
meu foco é sensacional fazer relaxamento
ainda há pouco estava aqui em os
primeiros mais difícil aqui hoje está no
estado concentra opções que estão
querendo fora do que o conforto
então foi uma técnica muito simples que
o técnico neca e demorou a falar que eu
vou olhar primitivo quem estes nem a que
horas vai marcar quando acabaram
totalmente tomadas não somente não podem
tocar que exista mais nenhum programa
acontece é que 99 gente nós sejamos
pensamos instituições que lhes vão
marcar minha primeira namorada que a
situação foi dado complicado em termos
familiares num ponto não situação na
escola
já não fica não quero e vou pôr os
tanques um do nosso inconsciente vários
marcando é que o pois são as nossas
ações conscientes e voces ter esta noção
porque vocês têm que aprender ou seja
obrigar o homem quando é necessário ser
feito e desligado quando é necessário
ser o pai como exemplo caiu e os
trabalhos se consegue fazer importando
quem vai a um ficou não vai ao
psiquiatra que servem de imprensa que
não se quer entrar numa fase em que já
estamos a olhar a ser regido eo
psicólogo pra mim serve como prevenção
como forma nós podemos trabalhar a nossa
- temos paixão os nossos cinco lados
mesmo em termos de negócio visa situada
no segundo gol
futuramente profissional não pode se
inscrever em mais de um mês tentando
superar isso e se vocês conseguirem ter
essa noção e trabalhar isso não ser
pessoas mais capazes cada vez mais dá
mais importância o está a forma como nós
continuamos nossas missões do que a
nossa presidente e portanto aprender a
fazer isto
o pessoal está um exemplo vão perdoá-lo
sei que o que eu mais gosto na
arbitragem
o mercado de cartões no bar vai
controlar o emocional - depois tentar
controlar o emocional menos 22 pessoas
em milésimos de segundo não é fácil
está muito igual amanhã temos
impressionei-me outras montagens
estávamos a tentar tirar o máximo do
mercado
o lateral estava para sair início é eu
tenho uma atleta nunca mais rápido ea um
carro que sai eo que é que eu faço
metáfora segundo passará para a nossa
janela do carro legal
um senhor ia entrar para o carro abri a
porta vai ter comigo mas a dizer que o
jogador vai começar a respirar na casa
dele em quarentena assim o roteiro matar
e eu mantenho o mesmo processo tranqüilo
sou autêntico sem fio
quando ela viu o pai inicial terminou o
convite já terminou
é o senhor começou a funcionar com um a
menos durante três minutos
quando coloquei os usuários podem dormir
num café de culpa
o primeiro foi feito ontem uma doença
terminal
o que houve foi um verde e eu vou
continuar correndo tudo aquilo que eu
tenho dentro de mim
isto serve para dizer o que nós avisa
final eu temos que aprender a ser ator
rola um véu neste ano
eu sou um ator enquanto o árbitro por
exemplo o papel será 20 anos mas estão
todos à vontade para continuar chamamos
a ordem tinha o papel estava montado não
preocupam muito mesmo nada aí que vocês
joão capela quando virei mesmo não vou
chamar o pessoal por exemplo não tem que
saber lidar com isso enquanto a onu
enquanto uma das aprendizagens tem muito
importantes univisa que me trouxe úm
difícil muita coisa e até em termos
familiares possível e também quando é
que tem que ser pai como é ser amigo
como é que tem que ser um livro quando é
que tem que ser amigo e perceber qual é
o papel naquele momento em determinadas
pessoas indefesas
quando nós começamos aspiro e começamos
a chegar ao topo da nossa carreira
acontece outra coisa é mais uma
aprendizagem a minha dimensão enquanto o
parâmetro com o sol ficar superior à
minha demissão enquanto ser uma passagem
posição procurei tanto conhecimento
jornais nos programas dos 77 programas
que visam que desistem do conhecimento
observador e chegou um pouco mais cômica
criar um monstro no rótulo e eu fui pra
casa e queria mudar eu não conseguir em
estávamos quase a fazer quer ser um
lindo gol possui que isso não pode
acontecer
a minha dimensão humana tem que ser
sempre superior à dimensão enquanto a
cair importante perceber cada situação
difícil da ok e que representa para mim
uma coisa e para os outros por exemplo
outra coisa é aquilo que é a minha
dimensão mas inferiorizados aquilo que
minha apresentação enquanto profissional
a compreender porque nós estamos no
caminho da de melhorarmos aquilo que nós
conseguimos controlar
começamos a ficar mensagem daquilo que é
um autoconhecimento e não o
autoconhecimento
eu não sei como é que o tempo da bola
tanto o que no fundo isto funciona tudo
na vida são funções humanas ponto final
por exemplo agora as redes sociais fazem
acho que deixam de investir em ações
humanas
estamos a criar o tipo de função da
relação que tem com ser em tudo na vida
é a raça humana
não tenho dúvidas disso é importante
você saber quem está montado nas redes
sociais fazer tudo isso porém da forma
que acham que é o mais comum com menos
mas por favor não esqueçam que a raça
humana é mais importante nós dependemos
uns dos outros isso nós realizamos muito
com o site amigo do facebook que temos
não conseguem
dá um chega prá mixed cantar outra
consciência
eu também queria partilhar todos são
esportistas
o desportista não é só praticar o
esportista ou dirigindo é o primeiro gol
e agora estamos todos os desportistas
nós também temos será universal estava
no desporto da forma correta isso foi
uma das grandes viragens a verdade que
eu fiz aquilo que é e como intimidade
muito grande e que era muito negativo eu
percebi que também poderia transformar
esta dimensão grandes sair do da parte
objetiva e na parte positiva
foi quando eu me envolvi no planeta
o primeiro é o quê
eu sou embora quando nacional de ética
desportiva e portanto neste momento eu
talvez muito a minha actividade da
corrupção passar os valores positivos o
esposo e faço em escolas faço isso
nestas acções passo nós só fomos boa e
faço um for necessário porque eu acho
que o elemento com o desporto é
contribuir com a evolução da sociedade e
se nós pensarmos no último campeonato
no futebol o futebol parece sol o
português tocou nós pensar num
campeonato que foi uma atuação do fim
sociedade último campeonato ganharão a
partir do marquês pombal todos os
prenderam
foram ter com os jogadores ao seu
estágio para quem não votou nem ganhar
sem saber o que vai ser bem interessante
não estamos aqui então vamos fazer uma
coisa pelo menos dar a perspectiva não é
minha casa onde aquelas pequeno
decorrente de cortarem muito positivos
são aqui vários o nosso tentar mexer no
passado e nosso foco é sempre muito nos
jogos das crianças está provado
incremento e os 3 14 anos irão mudar o
caráter de uma criança o que nós podemos
neste trabalho desenvolvendo de tentar
passar esta mensagem às crianças para
que elas possam ter a perceção e não
serem manipuladas em que o que é
o objetivo do tipo
outra das que esta foi o que inventar
primeiro ganharam com fair-play vencer e
nós temos que saber ganhar em primeiro e
importante mesmo vida às vezes as coisas
não correm bem
às vezes é o nosso qualifica a nossa
frente
naquela candidatura até o trabalho em
vida
vamos continuar temos que trabalhar mais
para escalar
não podemos misturar no sentido tático
não tomar sol e muito quem errou o
pleito foi pior
não deixaram escrito contra nós também
não funciona muito bem
introduzimos o cartão bancário um cartão
de frente em uma cela normal é um cartão
por uma das coisas positivas
os dois treinadores já fizemos
realizações trabalho também com equipes
vocês para inclusão social
ou seja nós já temos uma com uma ação
nas normas nacionais dos vários cursos
porto e fazemos um trabalho também na
tentativa de passar o que são as regras
infosfera new team exclusão social e com
graves problemas familiares com um
comportamento violento e é uma um tecido
uma um desafio vai efetivamente está
entendendo nós não fizermos um bar na
bola apenas para a sociedade muito
impulso se não tiver preço não quiser
vou continuar a fazer sempre aquilo que
eu acho que é uma idéia terminando quase
falando antes depois processo de
formação
eu antes chamavam alça já achava que
achava não era um encontro com passagens
eu não tinha noção que iria fazer as
coisas de frente deixava que sabe tudo
na vida
depois também tendo
era possível ver isso em frente
na hora que eu crio emocionante neste
momento à tona falso consenso com tempo
nossa gestão não consigo perceber o que
quase que são os meus objetivos o que eu
tenho que fazer como é que eu vou
aproveitar toda a semana sob traje não
termos tido um usuário desenvolver
humano é constatar o grau será todo e
tentar passar esta mensagem para você e
para quem quiser ouvir
o objetivo é ser um em contínuo contendo
as agências passaram a ser alguém não
ter que pensar que tem que fazer essas
coisas eu sempre quem sou e domingo
procurou o autoconhecimento novo pelos
gols positivos da vida e aproveitar as
minhas cunhadas e contribuir com o
desenvolvimento da sociedade
eu sinto isso podem dizer o que quiserem
em relação ao árbitro joão capela com a
cabeça mas eu enquanto ser humano sem
conhecer uma realizada a sessão de
conseguir sentir sim concepção as coisas